if you've been waiting on a package for
weeks your order might be here stuck at
sea in a shipping container
the coved pandemic has snarled global
supply chains causing massive backlogs
and shortages that have some companies
stockpiling goods and trailers and
chartering private container ships
but these are temporary fixes
for longer term solutions some companies
are looking to make sweeping changes to
their supply chains including shifting
manufacturing closer to home but pulling
off these strategies can require
retooling a complex web of global
production potentially adding new risks
and costs
first here's how a globally distributed
supply chain typically works
in this case for timberland's pit boss
boots a shoe the company sells to
consumers in the u.s and beyond source
map a website that publishes data about
supply chains says the materials
including the leather and metal details
are sourced from locations around the
world
including the us the uk china japan
south korea taiwan and vietnam all of
these materials are shipped to a factory
in bangladesh where the boots are
assembled the boots are transported to a
distribution center in virginia where
they're then shipped off to retail
locations and customers around the world
modern supply chains are are complex and
they're far flung jen smith has been
covering the forces behind the supply
chain issues for the wall street journal
she says that over the past few decades
supply chains have become increasingly
global
but every step along the way there is
the potential for disruption whether
it's in manufacturing or in transport or
if you're having trouble distributing it
once it gets here
lately disruptions have caused extensive
delays which has driven up the cost of
many goods
so some companies are looking at
different location strategies to protect
their supply chain and their bottom line
one idea being discussed in corporate
boardrooms is called regionalization
this involves setting up factories in
multiple parts of the world so that
operations in each region are able to
supply products to the closest markets
the idea is to minimize risk
supply chain problems happen all the
time the most common pre-pandemic is
something to do with a natural disaster
or a hurricane or a typhoon or something
affects uh the ability
to get stuff on the shelves of your
local grocery store so things are
emptied out and then that has a ripple
effect uh on the cost of transporting
goods so if a company is regionalized a
closed factory in one place only impacts
sales in nearby locations
companies are also looking at shortening
their supply chains through a similar
strategy called near shoring
the concept is pretty simple it refers
to the practice of pulling production
that had been moved far away back to a
country closer to where the products are
distributed and sold
and this strategy is becoming more
popular
after facing shortages the italian
clothing company benetton decided to
increase manufacturing in serbia croatia
turkey tunisia and egypt closer to where
the products are sold in europe
it's a big move
the company plans to cut its asia
production by half over the next year or
so
it's a reversal of the decades-long
shift by many apparel companies to asian
factories that offered low-cost supplies
some companies are also using a strategy
called reshoring it's similar to
near-shoring but in this case a company
that previously moved manufacturing
overseas
moves it back to the country where it
was originally located
with re-shoring a business may choose to
move some of its manufacturing that it
had been doing elsewhere back to the u.s
if it had experienced
trouble getting the products here
whether there wasn't enough production
capacity abroad or whether there were
transportation bottlenecks that were
preventing
products from getting here when they
were needed
while moving production could solve some
supply chain issues these solutions
aren't a fix-all and they still carry
risks
mainly they're expensive to pull off
according to a 2020 report the total
combined cost for u.s and european
companies to move manufacturing out of
china would come to some one trillion
dollars over the next five years
and for many smaller companies the costs
are too high to bear
some companies may not have enough money
to set up manufacturing domestically and
even if they did it might not make sense
because their product might end up
costing twice as much as it does so they
are going to have to weigh
the the cost of delays of a product
that's made elsewhere getting here what
does that mean for their bottom line
versus would they have as many buyers
for that product if they were making it
domestically
and it cost twice as much
overhauling entire supply chains can
also take years
still some companies think these
strategies could pay dividends for the
future
and help their businesses survive
[Music]
you